There are many ways to deal with a close-minded boss.
Some are right and some are simply wrong.
Here are three things you should avoid doing.
Number one: Don't ignore your boss as this will only emphasize a lack of interest and respect...
...and will ultimately create a gap between the two of you.
Number two: Don't push your point of view with aggression...
...as this will only put your boss in a defensive state,...
...and he will less likely be open to your ideas.
Number three: Don't try to prove that you are better than your boss.
This is counterproductive and will leave your boss feeling inadequate.
Instead, think about these three suggestions.
Number one: Consider the fact that you may be wrong.
Take the time to reflect on your thoughts and find middle ground.
Number two: Patience goes a long way.
So, keep that smile on your face and be cool.
And finally, incorporate your ideas with your boss' ideas.
This way, both of you can eventually come together and agree.
Never stop pursuing common ground...
...as this can be the foundation for a better relationship.
How have you dealt with a close-minded boss in the past?
Feel free to share some of your experiences below.
And for more career and resume writing advice, visit us at www.resumeserviceplus.com.